first and foremost we want to tell the
right story and I think with JJ and
Larry at the helm absolutely the right
stories being told in the best possible
way there are stories about what
happened it's true I was delighted with
the opportunity to come back and be part
of the telling of this story with the
force awakens we're definitely telling a
story we haven't told it's exciting that
people don't really know what they got
to expect and then they're gonna go and
see this thing and hopefully be blown
away by it new characters are introduced
and Han Solo is part of the telling of
their stories we have characters that
we've seen before but the new characters
kind of bring this new freshness and
this new lightness look bringing some
real joy a little bit of a kind of
subversiveness into it they don't behave
you know there's a little bit rebellious
in nature and I think that's gonna be
really fun in Star Wars everyone has
always been important no story kind of
works without all of the other
characters working with it it's like a
very inclusive cast and an inclusive
story because of that it's wonderful to
play cuz II don't feel alone you feel
part of an incredible cast of people
right needs us JJ was such a great
leader who kazi's just got such a big
heart and he's so talented at what he
does and he really did create a feeling
of community I really am a big fan of JJ
so it was all together a great
experience to come back and work on this
fellow
just that first day walking on set as
Captain phasma as a new character as a
progressive female character into this
world onto these huge huge sets it
really was stepping into another world
it was stepping into Star Wars it's
really exciting to be involved with
something that you know I just watched
since I was a kid it's a very surreal I
really was very overwhelmed that I was
getting to be in this film with three
members of the original cast holding in
high esteem the authenticity of Star
Wars what that's about why people love
it but bringing it into the modern day
you just got to go in there and take
ownership of it and make it make a
believable interesting compelling
character that's the responsibility but
also it's a thrill to create and add
something to this it's not exciting
enough franchise is a cultural
phenomenon it's American mythology the
force it's calling to you when I think
about when I first saw the films I was
so little Michael I want to be in Star
Wars film and I was told they don't make
many
and now they have made them again and I
am in them that is a proper dream come
true
you